FOUL, THERE WAS A LOT OF CONTACT
ON THE
THEY CLOLO OPENING.
>> AND THE SI
UNDERNEATH. IF YOU'RE STEVE
KERR, CURRY MAKES BOTH 3 O OUT
DOUBLE PLAY, KEEPING 20.
JAMES WITH
RIGHT THERE HIM OR -- DIDN'T
EVEN T MISSED EVERYTHING.
>> DE'ANTHONY MELTON.
>> Bob: WEIGH SAY IT ALL OF IN .
>> Bob:: IN
BETWEEN ANDREW WIGGINS, I THINK.
A LITTLE BIT STRONG, GREEN.
TURNOVER.
PAYTON FINDING GREEN UP TOP AND.
WIGGINS AT THE HORN, AND IT'S
GOOD!
>> Stan: SAS STATE.TEAM.
>> Bob: DRAYMOND.
HE AND WIGGINS ARE REALLY A PIEF
THE GAME THAT SAID THIS WOULD BE
DOFF
IS JUST TRAVELING THROUGH THE N
AS HAS A SIZEOU GOT
TO MOVE.
GIVE HEM AN OUTLET, DRAYMOND
GREEN DOES.
LANE.
STEPH CURRY. OFF OF THIS.D,
THIS TIME THEY FINISH THE
DEFENSIVE POSSESSION.
TRAILING PLATE.
READS IT WITHL FINISH.
SPERO: CUT, YOU CANNOT H
ENERGY.
HARRISON B B
PAYTON, II.
>> Bob: THE BEAUTY OF THAT IS
DRAYMOND THAT TIME, THINKING HE
WAS OPEN IN THE MIDDLE.
>> B
GREEN JUST
DRAYMOND PUTS IT DIDN'T
POSITION.SPINS,
>> Bob: DRAYMOND FROM THE
26-POINT GAME LAST NIGHT AGAINST
INDIAN.
THAT AND G
>> Doris: LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE IN
A LITTLEE PERFECT FEED BACK TO
FOR THE SLAM. LEAD.
BJEL GAME LAST NIGHT
AGAINST THE BROOKLYN WATCH,
>> Bob:ENT 0 FOR 6 AND
DID NOT SCORE CHATTING AWAY LIK
THAT WHILE THEIR SONS GO AT IT.T
ON.
SIX GUYS IN DOUBLE FIGURES.
YOU LIKE
WARRIORS, TALKING ABOUT DAMION
LEE'S FLOATER.
DRAYMOND WITH